Oh everyone in
today's live broadcast genotyping to
enable large-scale precision medicine
research studies presented by dr. mark
bucyk the co-founder and chief
scientific officer of a key surgeon
incorporated i'm susie valdez and I'll
be your moderator for this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by thermo Fisher Scientific to
learn more about our sponsor
Thermo Fisher Scientific please visit
their website at thermo Fisher com
before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time during the presentation just
click on that green Q&A button located
in the lower left of the presentation
window type your question into the box
that appears on the screen and we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for at the end of the presentation also
notice that you'll be viewing this
presentation in a slide window to
enlarge that window just click on the
screen icon located at the lower right
of your screen if you have trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation
click on the support button at the top
right or use that Q&A button and let us
know you're having a problem this
educational webinar and and thus offers
free continuing education credits after
the webinar is over click on the seee
button located at the bottom left hand
corner of your webpage and follow the
process for obtaining your credits our
speaker today is dr. mark music dr. mark
bucyk is a co-founder and chief
scientific officer at a custodian a
genomics pharmacogenomics and bio
banking company based at the Greater
Atlanta region in Georgia USA prior to a
piece of gin dr. bucyk spent five years
as a faculty member in the Department of
Human Genetics at Emory University in
Atlanta Georgia
during his tenure at Emory he served as
a director of Emory biomarkers service
center director of basic research shared
core resources at the Emory Winship
Cancer Institute as well as the director
of the center for medical genomics which
he established welcome dr. bucyk
please begin thanks very much Suzy and
thanks everyone for having me
we appreciate the sponsorship of our
thermo Fisher Scientific applied by
systems as well as our lab roots of
course and welcomed the opportunity to
discuss the approaches of genotyping to
enable large-scale precision medicine
research studies so this presentation
will put into context the background of
a new breed of service provider which is
a key surgeon and set into contact
genotyping in the space of precision
medicine and what I will do is I will go
over a number of examples of our
experiences of the service provider in
this space and that will be namely
including our work with the VA million
veteran program describing the flagship
applied by systems precision medicine
research array and the recently released
pharmaco scan array I will touch on the
new microbiome array as well as give
examples on custom arrays such as our
own DTC or direct consumer axiom array
as well as the novel Alzheimer's disease
dementia array now offered by our
partner site ox and then finally I will
summarize all of this and hopefully
convince you that arrays still have an
important place or a very important
place in genomics and its applications
actually I'm always asked what is a key
surgeon mean so I always put up this
slide okey so is the Greek goddess of
healing and curing and essentially
that's the essence of our company
this next slide this next slide really
describes as a service company water
kiss agent does we essentially have
three verticals the first vertical
covers our multi-omics approach to
precision medicine we offer biobanking
nucleic acid extractions from pretty
much any starting material we offer
genotyping copy number variant analysis
transcriptomics methylation
next-generation sequencing we offer
forensic work and pathology as well as
direct consumer genetics we also develop
new assays pertaining to our customers
requests so we offer the whole gamut of
multi-omics services and in addition we
offer clinical clear and cap testing we
currently have an oncology microarray
test that covers most solid and liquid
tumors as well as the recently developed
proteomics Alzheimer's cerebral spinal
fluid test moreover we are now
intimately involved in clinical trials
to utilize precision medicine to
stratify populations and optimize
clinical trial design we use all of the
above technologies and capabilities in
our R&D services for our clinical trials
for example performing reproducibility
studies and can work all the way from
preclinical all the way to phase form as
well as developing new assays for our
former clients in order to do this as
I've touched on we are clear and cap
accredited and our quality management
system works to GCP
I thought I'd show this graph I
developed several months ago based on
the number of citations in PubMed it
shows over the last 10 years or so the
rapid number of publications citing NGS
or next generation sequencing which
continues to increase rapidly and here
it's from around 7,000 publications or
citations to around 24,000 interestingly
although genotyping has not increased as
dramatically it certainly continues to
increase and absolutely shows no signs
of going away also the cost of
microarrays has become highly highly
affordable in my day back in 2005 they
were about 30 times more expensive than
they are today
so this now allows investigators to
consider new experiments that were not
feasible a decade or so ago the axiom
microarrays have many diverse
applications
these range from interrogating the
microbiome and I'll briefly touch on
that later there are no important
applications as well in biobanking and
these arrays are beginning to be used in
forensic applications for example we use
them for cold case investigations and
all for discover disaster
identifications arrays are used by many
as a QC tool for sequence validation for
instance and there are wide-ranging
applications in agriculture which alone
could be the subject of another talk
many of you know that arrays are also
used in the direct consumer space it for
example Frances retesting and finally of
course there are a wide ranging
applications for them in medicine
of which I will focus on some
applications today because of the low
cost of the raise are now being utilized
to annotate biobank samples and in many
buy banks this is becoming part of the
typical SOP doing it prospectively as
well as retrospectively this really
creates an outstandingly valuable
resource for industry including large
pharma and there are examples of
large-scale well known bio banks across
the u.s. Europe and the world some of
which are shown on this slide and as you
can see here the ones marked in red
indicate bio banks that are collecting
genomic data as part of a value add for
prospective and retrospective studies
well-known examples include the Kaiser
bio Bank to end the million veteran
program and UK by banks as well as by
banks in Brazil Japan and China so
moving on to the million veterans
program being run by the US Department
of Veterans Affairs or VA when this
project began several years ago it was
one of the largest or the largest
genomics project of its kind with the
initial remit to genotype a million US
veterans over five years it is really
all about understanding how genes affect
health and using the VA healthcare
system as a model it is a voluntary
system for taking part and the key
advantage here is that the phenotypes or
clinical information are linked to a
single provider healthcare system it
could be that some of the outcomes of
the study may give unique findings into
certain diseases which may be more
prevalent in veterans
for background information on learning
about the study I would recommend
reviewing this paper in the journal of
clinical epidemiology the VA continues
to enroll participants for more than 60
sites across the u.s. it has now
enrolled more than 600,000 veterans and
is on track to reach its goal of a
million veterans by 2020 basically a
tube of blood is collected in an EDTA -
and plasma and DNA are stored in the VA
maverick by repository in Boston DNA is
then shipped out to us for processing
and genotyping on the axiom gene Titan
platform so what is the axial genotyping
platform essentially it's an end-to-end
suite of solutions where initially one
can select from the database of around
about twenty six million Aust or Soviet
variants both common and rare across 13
different populations then custom or
off-the-shelf arrays can be designed and
typically say a thousand five hundred
snips all the way up to a million snips
per array or pag usually in 96 or
384-well formats then there are a number
of steps which can be done manually or
ideally automated and include various
hybridization ligation and more steps
before scanning on the gene Titan
scanner and then analysis of the data
using the axiom analysis suite and if
you want a more detailed understanding
of the workflow I would recommend you go
to the URL on the thermo Fisher
Scientific website indicated on this
slide so this next slide shows the snip
content of the million veteran program
array as you can see the major
includes fish nets in Dell variants for
excellent content novel exome and
loss-of-function variants as well as
markers for eqtls in addition the VA has
selected markers internally to support
this project such as markers for PTSD or
post-traumatic stress disorder
susceptibility to give you an idea of
the size of the VA million veterans team
a topping project here is a picture of
one of our employees taking delivery of
a stock of samples just for this project
alone it literally takes up the the
hallway of our large facility and this
picture shows rows and rows of firma
fish Affymetrix kids stacked up upon
each other as part of that quarterly
delivery literally to put in context a
couple of these boxes could constitute
someone's complete PhD project and here
is a picture of a couple of our
scientists working in situ on the VA
project in our laboratories particularly
on the Left showing show unloading the
back when FXP as one of the automated
steps in the process as well as a
picture of one of our several Teen
Titans we genotype more than 300,000
veterans to date over the last few years
our capacity is up to 3,000 samples per
day although we have genotyped as high
as a thousand veterans per day so what
has been our process well we received
DNA from the VA in 2d bar coded matrix
tubes the DNA concentrations are
verified by a Pico green assay the VA
provides blinded duplicates as part of
their internal QC process for variation
of concordance and for such a large
project we have been delighted with the
call rates of greater than 99 percent
when the Affymetrix thresholds and 97
percent and the failure rate to date has
been less than 1% we then returned the
data to the VA on the hard drives
Purvi a guidance and specifications so
moving forward what are the va plans for
this project I don't may have mentioned
the plan is to definitively continue
collecting samples to a million by 2020
but the VA does not want to stop there
and they want to keep on going well
beyond the million also the VA intends
to expand compute power to
simultaneously support more than a
thousand users in addition the intention
is to create a secure by repository at
another location as a backup to the
current site in Boston and finally the
most important or the biggest challenge
will be to work out ways and means to
share data and results with the
providers and their electronic health
records as well as the VA patients
themselves there have already been
several active funded projects to date
they're already generating publication
ready data and these include projects
such as PTSD susceptibility and veterans
studies in cardiovascular disease cardio
metabolic disease kidney disease and
macular degeneration as well as projects
looking into gulf warren illness and
substance abuse and all of these
projects typically require participation
of VA investigators and at the ASHG
meeting happening this year in 2017 in
October the VA will be presenting a lot
of this data
and recently the VA has expanded its
base of subjects in this landmark study
in February last year President Obama
announced extending this project to
active duty personnel there are
approximately two million active duty
personnel in the u.s. in addition to the
802 nine million US veterans in addition
the VA project will be closely aligned
with the new and well-known all of us
project which plans to collect a million
samples as a cross-section of the US
population it is intended that some of
his cohorts will be sourced from the VA
project and so the all of us or
precision medicine initiative cohort
will essentially be a sister or cousin
project of the million veteran program
so now moving on to discuss thermo
Fisher's flagship human array this is
the axiom precision medicine research
array and it has tremendous versatility
and is primarily used to genotype to toy
to perform genome-wide Association
studies across global populations so
what is the key content of this array
that makes it uniquely attractive to
support a multitude of research studies
it contains for example 800,000 snips
that cover Europeans East Asians Native
Americans Africans and South Asians with
minor allele frequencies between 1 to 5%
there are nearly 50,000 functional
variants including eqtls and functional
non-coding variants there are also
around 2,000 or so blood phenotype
variants as well the array also contains
snips for sample tracking
quality control as well as significant
content for pharmacogenetics and HLA
markers and finally there is a broad in
your unique focus on clinical research
variants which are shown in more detail
on the next slide these clinical
variants include markers covering more
than 3000 genes from the clinvar
database as well as nearly 9,000
pathogenic markers which are cited by
the American College of genetics and
genomics here are shown unique contents
for genes such as Apple for Alzheimer's
Braca 1 in bracket 2 for breast cancer
CFTR for cystic fibrosis and DMD for
muscular dystrophy the array also covers
literally hundreds of human diseases and
conditions there are markers for most
cancer types or subtypes inflammatory
and autoimmune markers such as Crohn's
disease and celiac disease markers for
mental behavioral and neurodevelopmental
disorders including schizophrenia and
autism cardiovascular markers and
markers for various health factors such
as alcohol and even smoking dependence
so the precision medicine research array
has outstanding imputation accuracy as
you can see on the left for one of the
most challenging ethnic groups are
Africans it's as high as 0.9 and point 9
3 with greater than 1% and 5% minor
allele frequency respectively and there
are as many as 14 point five million
markers that can actually be imputed
imputed with an r-squared of greater
than 0.8 for snips with a minor allele
frequency of greater than 1% for
Africans
the precision medicine research array as
a highly accurate genotyping record in
this case 270 hapmap samples were run on
three separate plates and call rates
components reproducibility rates are
well all above 99.5% and in the
real-world situation when we get
genotyping clients or collaborators own
DNA and we routinely report outstanding
data quality for example in this
narcolepsy study with Stanford
University we genotype 288 samples and
call rates were greater than 99% and
failure rates again were less than 1%
which is pretty much the same quality
we've been getting with a million
veteran program I thought I'd uh briefly
say something and give some brief
comments about the axiom analysis
software suite basically the software is
highly intuitive and user-friendly and
downloadable from the thermo Fisher
Scientific website it certainly handles
large datasets and has a very very
straightforward and simplified workflow
and sheer the announces configuration
window has already preset default as
well as customizable settings and you
can set all your parameters or
thresholds once the summary window and
plate for you is very intuitive as well
as laid out here you can see batch
sample plate and snip information
locally segregated and the snip
the plots and summary tables are very
very easy to understand and manage so
moving on to a quick overview of
pharmacogenetics basically
pharmacogenetic assays allow a physician
to provide a patient with precision
treatment by selecting the drug that is
more efficacious or more likely to work
at the same time minimizing side-effects
there are now more than 300 genetic
markers would you believe that are
actionable with dosing guidelines for
fda-approved drugs and in fact of the
1,200 fda-approved Matt's into to date 7
percent of them are affected by
pharmacogenetic markers and 18 percent
of all the 4 billion prescriptions in
the u.s. today are also affected by
pharmacogenetic markers which shows the
increase at new portance of knowing more
about pharmacogenetics and now coming
back to the precision medicine research
array this product has most of the
pharmacogenetic markers that are
interesting to the research community
and on this array it comprises more than
a thousand markers for 300 genes for key
drug target genes such as Apple II drug
transporter gene such as o 80 P 1 and
drug metabolizing genes such as sip to
d6 + 2 C 19 so there's a good quality
pharmacogenetic content just on the
precision medicine research array
however the two main pharmacogenetic
projects that are well known
I either D med cartridge and two new
axiom pharmacopeia scan array a specific
products that have been developed in the
pharmacogenetics world by thermo Fisher
FM a
Drix and this table compares the two
technologies essentially the d-mat
solution is really a clinical solution
used in the low volume one sample at a
time with nearly 2000 markers in 231
genes and the software allows
translation of star of the star allele
format for the important genes and the
pharmaco scan array is much more
high-throughput
typically doing batches of 24 samples or
specimens at a time and really has the
most comprehensive coverage that's an
astonishing 4600 plus markers comprising
1191 genes and what is unique about the
pharma Kreskin array uniquely the real
estate on this array captures copy
number variation or CMV and Alice's for
copy number states ranging from 0 all
the way to 3 copies and Beyond for
important aadmi genes as well as in
Dells and is genotyped highly predictive
markers in genes such as SEP 26 again
set to C 19 said and sipped to C 9 which
are in highly homologous regions so the
content for the pharmaco scan was
actually selected by key opinion leaders
and consortium around the world
including the clinical pharmacogenetics
implementation consortium and the
pharmacogenomics knowledge base from a
research point of view it truly is the
most comprehensive pharmacogenetics
array on the market today including CPIC
genes copy number teams and haplotype
calling genes again as I've shown for
previous erase the concordance and call
rates are all above 99%
as exemplified by this study from four
different independent sites and in this
slide we can see tighter cluster plots
for important and difficult to genotype
pharmacogenetic markers using the
thousand genomes project and calls as a
comparator compared to the pharmaco scan
axiom cause these examples shown here
include the star 303 allele for SIP 3 a5
the star 3 allele for sip to see 19 as
well as the star for a level 4 sep 2015
19
- with of genetic markers read for 1
copy number green for to copy numbers
and blue for 3 copy numbers you can see
the variants are tightly grouped for the
discrete copy numbers ok so moving on I
wanted to briefly introduce a new array
that was recently launched for the new
and exciting field of microbiome
analysis genomic technologies has really
opened up this this new area mainly in
sequencing however this new product does
have some really exciting attributes I
really wanted to highlight that the
axiom microbiome array allows profiling
of all five
organisms present in the sample and
these five organism
are bacteria viruses fungi archaea as
well as protozoa which i think is a
unique strength for this assay on this
product piece of the other assays there
is high resolution of the species strain
and sequence the array interrogate more
than 12,000 microbiota kheh
and of course the applications are
enormous primarily in animal research
the AG market and nutrigenomics and this
next slide simply gives a breakdown of
the number of families number of species
and number of target sequences which are
1,350 135 thousand basically comprising
the five different species the array
performance has been evaluated on both
known complex mixtures and real
biological samples for example still the
true positive rates and positive
predictive value were evaluated on 222
samples of known composition with
complexity ranging from 1 to 22 strains
per sample
now strain level resolution is really
dependent upon sequence information in
the reference database as an example
highly related strain term actually
share probes with the detected strain
due to similarity of genomic sequence
this probe sharing can lead to a
database target with less complete
annotation being the best explanation of
the summarized Pro intensity data moving
on again we Atticus adjourn launched at
the start of this year
direct-to-consumer axiom array the
900,000 snap content consists really of
three components it has a large number
of snips from the precision medicine
research array there are clients
specific snips and we have our own
proprietary content our whole model is
really a b2b model that is we run our
array for multiple clients which range
from a dozen small to large businesses
we provide these consumer companies with
their markers of interest and these
businesses then report the data to their
individual clients running the same
array for multiple businesses actually
allows us to provide highly competitive
pricing and we offer that whole
end-to-end solution starting with saliva
or swar sworps
to snip data output and our applications
have been pretty expensive primarily
most offerings in the health and
wellness space tackling athletic prowess
for example fitness and applications in
areas such as weight management so this
is a product with we've developed and we
can and we're looking to launch a
version two next year the final part of
the presentation will introduce you to a
new array for domain where dementia is
developed by SCI tox a company in the UK
in a nutshell this array has more than
130,000 snaps and has and is used to
identify individuals at risk of
cognitive decline and has been initially
used for late onset Alzheimer's disease
so socks have developed a polygenic wig
or using the very attacked and snip fit
technology for aspirin for assessing
Alzheimer's disease risk
now the polygenic risk score is based on
a number of algorithms utilizing both a
hypothesis driven based model and an on
hypothesis more approach as well as an
algorithm based on the mTOR pathway that
have been developed over the last few
years some of the obvious challenges for
Alzheimer's early detection before
tangible symptoms appear or that of
invasiveness via lumbar puncture or
expensive brain amyloid imaging via PET
scanning so there is an urgent need for
a simple non-invasive blood based
biomarker test or an actual fact that
could potentially be a non-invasive
saliva based test the 130-thousand snips
have been sourced from a number of areas
they come from a whole host of
genome-wide Association studies as well
as navigating the academic literature
over the past several years
mark has also had been sought from
Alzheimer's disease genes involved in
the amyloid pathway and other areas
including genes involved in if
information endocytosis cholesterol
metabolism as well as the mTOR pathway
itself in addition markers were selected
from whole exome sequence data from
well-known cohorts such as the able data
as mentioned previously the two main
models used so far for algorithm
training of the hypothesis model one and
then on hypothesis which is modeled to
the risk score models have been trained
and tested on cerebral spinal fluid
confirmed specimens or pet amyloid
positive samples the subjects for the
training have come from right across the
whole disease spectrum that is cognate
cognitively normal mild cognitive
impairment or MCI to probable
Alzheimer's disease all cases are
amyloid positive via lumbar puncture or
PET imaging now primarily validation has
been performed by blinding clinically
assessed postmortem pathology confirmed
cases and controls the training set of
703 samples came from three Caucasian
cohorts that's a cohort from site ox da
ville' cohorts and the University of
Sorbonne that were age and sex matched
with 35 percent amyloid positive 31
percent a pony for carriers nine percent
MCI and 15 percent Alzheimer's disease
the blinded test of 300 samples came
from the same three Caucasian cohorts
with 34% in this case amyloid pork
positive 35 percent a buii for carriers
12 percent MCI and 17 percent
Alzheimer's a similar breakdown to the
initial training set the key finding was
that the hypothesis free variant model 2
had a positive predictive value of
Alzheimer's detection of wait for this
of 89% with an AUC o arian with the
serve of 94% and when these algorithms
were run on an independent test set of
237 brain bank samples from you pan in
this case the positive predictive value
for the hypothesis driven model was
95.8%
and the hypothesis free model still
performs incredibly well at over 91% PPV
note in this cohort the number of
amyloid cases was 88% and Alzheimer's
disease was 53% therefore this new
technology now provides a great great
opportunity to affordably stratify
patients for clinical trial recruitment
and reducing the screening failure rate
of course optimizing clinical trials and
potential companion diagnostic
approaches other benefits would of
course included reducing pet and CSF
procedures so to conclude this section
two basic models or algorithms have been
developed with more than a thousand
samples the blinded validation study has
been successful for both models showing
a true positive rate of greater than 95
percent and also a true negative rate of
60 sets of 76 percent is possible which
was not presented here and the models
are much better that what is out there
today with a bowi
for Alzheimer's risk detection much much
better and as I've mentioned in this
tool has significant possibilities for
clinical trial optimization and
companion diagnostics
development and so to summarize the talk
today I hope I've convinced you that
micro arrays are still a very very
important in large-scale genotyping
today's pricing allows scientists to
really consider experiments never before
feasible and the suite of new axiom
arrays provide high high utility in many
different disease and therapeutic areas
and finally quality and turnaround time
will absolutely keep microarrays front
and center as a crucial tool for
precision medicine I'd like to
acknowledge the US Department of
Veterans Affairs the team at Stanford
University and sight ox as well as our
our team at a kitchen and finally I'd
like to thank the folks at thermo Fisher
for sponsoring today's presentation if
anyone would like to contact me or any
of our team at a kitchen to learn more
please do not hesitate to contact me by
phone or email contact details are shown
on this slide here thank you for your
time today
and with that I'd like to hand it back
to our monitor moderator Susie Valdes
Susie over to you thank you so much dr.
Busiek and thank you for your
informative presentation and your
important research audience members we
will now start the live Q&A portion of
the webinar if you have any questions
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on that green Q&A button at the
lower left of your presentation window
type your questions into the box that
appear on the screen and click the send
button
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for so let's take a look at
our questions that are already coming in
dr. Dusek our first question from our
audience is do you think with cost of
sequencing rapidly decreasing that
genotyping will be superseded completely
by sequencing yeah thank you for that
question that's a question that a lot of
people want to know and understand and
it's an important one to answer
especially how in today's age when
people are planning NGS vs. arrays
I don't believe genotyping or microarray
genotyping is going away anytime soon as
an analogy as we saw with Sanger
sequencing versus NGS for example saying
is still used today as an important tool
for clinically validating NGS in many
diagnostic and clinical labs it is still
considered the gold standard in many
clinical laboratories and so in the same
way microarrays are used and will
continue to be used as an orthogonal
quality control for NGS especially whole
genome sequencing and many many people
who do holds the genome sequencing today
absolutely as part of their QC will
always run the microarray so hopefully
that gives you a general answer to that
question great thank you so much and
here's a wonderful question from an
audience member about your company
I hadn't heard of okey so Jen before
this webinar what is the company's
vision and mission in the next five
years okay great question thanks for for
that question I thought as I may have
mentioned the key Siachen really sees
itself as a new breed of precision
medicine focused CRO or contract
research organization
that supports not only farmer but other
CR o--'s who want to be in the precision
medicine space to generate genomic as
well as pathology data so the merit of
genomics and pathology we believe is
going to be very very important in the
future especially in the world of human
immuno and quality and this data is of
the highest quality at all stages of
clinical trials the kind of data
generated would be used to stratify
cohorts optimize clinical trials in this
some of the examples I gave today as
well as for companion diagnostics we
really see this area growing
considerably in the coming years and
intend to be front and center for this
new way for precision focus medicines so
hopefully that gives you an idea of our
company and where we see ourselves going
in the coming years and also not only in
the u.s. we really see ourselves as
doing all of these things as a global
service provider in Europe and Asia as
well as the US where we print where we
are already and also providing
standardized and harmonized services in
all of these areas across the world
thank you dr. Bozek our next question is
how can I get access to the data you are
generating for the million veteran
program ok great question
yes there is a process to there's no
been asked it several times so what you
need to do is to go to a Fed biz gov and
see if there are any requests for
proposals or RFPs
that the VA has announced the VA
announces these from time to time if
there are any there at all
or any suitable ones you would simply
apply as for any normal grants or
contract process I believe that
typically the VA
expects there to be at least one VA
investigator as part of that team that
is applying or alternatively what I
would do is or another alternative is
you can contact the VA million veteran
program directly and I'm happy to
provide a link if need be to do that to
ask them what they may be planning or
whether they're planning to launch their
next tranche of RFPs and what the topics
might be as you can see there's a lot of
data being generated at the moment and
there's a lot of interest in now getting
access to that data primarily in a
research context to improve the health
and well-being not only of veterans but
taking it beyond veterans to the larger
community
thank you dr. guzik that's so wonderful
and thank you audience members for your
live participation we have some
wonderful questions continuing to come
in our next question is can you tell me
more about your direct-to-consumer array
and how can it compete with helixes
offering of I think it's 23andme yes so
I get off this question of a lot as well
well as I may have mentioned our array
contains 900,000 snips and that's
version one for this year which include
a lot of the content of the precision
medicine research array plus a lot of
customer content and is certainly
competitively priced also it in our
business model we do not keep or store
any customer data now with respect to
helixes whole exome sequencing approach
right now if you compare the return on
useful markers from a consumer stands
you can get just as much useful
information today from an array as you
can from whole exome sequencing now sure
you get a whole lot of more information
from exome sequencing
but we do not know what 99.9% or that
means today maybe in a decade or more we
may learn more from exomes
but largely in this direct consumer
space exome sequencing is okay for
building databases for the future but in
my opinion has limited value at least
today for you and I as a consumer or as
a consumer of segments
thank you our next question is I'm
interested in learning more about the
site ox array for Alzheimer's where can
I get more information and can I get it
into my healthcare system okay this is a
very interesting product and love to
tell you more about this yes I agree it
is a very promising tool for
non-invasive late onset Alzheimer's
disease risk detection I think the next
step would be to also put you in touch
with our partners at site ox I can
certainly put you in touch with Kevin
banks who is the head of global business
development at site ox or you can
contact him contact him directly by
emailing Kevin banks at site ox
group.com but in general terms with
respect to getting it into the
healthcare system I believe risk based
assays such as this one will become more
a common in the health care setting over
time but must must be driven by
physicians in order to better convince
patients to change their habits or for a
healthier lifestyle for example if a
doctor tells you you have a higher risk
of stroke or heart attack whatever
because there is a history in the family
in the family is important if this risk
can be highlighted from a genetic risk
score and so much the better in
providing these tools to positions to
help better manage health care even
though reimbursement may still be an
issue I think this is a work in progress
and will become part of the system over
time thank you so much dr. music and
thanks again for our audience we have
time for one more question we end it
with this question I was happy to see
you introduced that you introduced a
micro Blom
Oh bye-bye I'm so sorry I was happy to
see you introduce the micro biome array
as I was not aware of this product do
you know of any publications or white
papers on the array yes great question
yes I am actually aware of one white
paper with the micro biome array is
compared with 16s next-generation
sequencing and I believe one of the
conclusions is that the microbiome array
has a higher resolution than 16s I would
actually suggest that you go or
recommend that the people listening in
to go to the thermo Fisher Scientific
website and download that paper and
learn more about it it's a very exciting
tool that can be used very very quickly
and certainly as a scientist I'd be
looking and comparing and contrasting
the microbiome array with the 16s and
Beyond NGS for the best photo product
for my scientific research wonderful
thank you so much again dr. with it did
you have any closing remarks you'd like
to provide for our audience before we
close today yes in general terms what
I'd like to say because hopefully some
my passion in this area of personalized
and precision medicine is coming across
I'm convinced that genetics is becoming
more and more pervasive in our society
from all aspects of our lives now this
would include anything from performing
ancestry tests to seeing how genetics
plays a part in the health and
well-being such as things like weight
management to understanding your risk
for breast cancer as well or Alzheimer's
to whether a drug will work for you or
give you a side effect to even studying
how your fluoro microbiome
affect your health and these are just a
few examples and today all of these
modalities can be well studied using
large-scale genotyping technologies
particularly the axiom precedes the
axiom arrays suite at a key surgeon we
are well positioned to execute on these
studies as one of our strengths is
actually being one of the largest
genotyping facilities in the US and
notwithstanding being a global provider
as well for genomic technologies and
pathology and marrying those two
disciplines our core competency is
generating data of the highest quality
and so once again if you have any
further questions on any of these topics
or if you had a question that did not
get answered or to know that there
wasn't enough time to have it answered
please do feel free to email me at your
earliest convenience
thank you once again for spending your
time with me today thank you very much
dr. Buzek thank you so much for a
wonderful presentation and I must to
also thank lab rates and of course our
sponsor Thermo Fisher Scientific for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to remind
everyone that today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
April 2018 you'll receive an email from
Roberts letting you know when this
webcast will be available for replay
please please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
and thanks so much for joining us we
hope to see you again soon goodbye